uh-huh Rob Porter I don't some of you
guys are probably just like oh god here
we go
Clone Saga really okay here's the deal
Clone Saga is a huge story I mean it's
been saying it's the perfect example of
what happens when a publisher runs away
with a story and makes it a lot more
complicated than it needs to be like 95%
of the stuff that happens in Clone Saga
doesn't matter but there's like five
person that does and the stuff that does
matter is extremely important so what
we're going to do is we basically
condense the Clone Saga down and what
we're going to do is we're going to do
this in four videos alright the first
video the one we're doing now is going
to focus on Ben Riley the second video
is going to focus on Cain the third
video is going to be the trial of Peter
Parker which is where everything kind of
comes to a head and then we're going to
do the conclusion now my ability to do
this Clone Saga video comes by way of
sal over at comedy pop so you guys need
to go over to his channel and say what's
up check out his videos that kind of
thing but he's like the most
knowledgeable person when it comes to
spider-man that I know of because he's
been reading it forever so I mean like
he was born and raised on spider-man and
so because of that I went to him and I
said okay look if like Lauren saga was
released today and it was like 12 or 13
15 20 issues story whatever it is a
limited series what stories would there
be to comprise that limited series and
he's like I see where you're going so he
sends me like a list of like 16 comics
that matter and I was like okay cool so
I just kind of you know went through and
you know added bits and pieces and
subtracted bits and pieces and so on but
it's made it possible for us to actually
do this so here's the deal about clown
saga Clone Saga goes all the way back to
1975 really the mid 1970s but the caveat
to this is that there's two of them when
people say man I hate spider-man Clone
Saga they're talking about the second
Clone Saga they're not talking about the
first one the first one was pretty sure
it wasn't a great big huge drawn-out
thing it was really just like the
introduction of Mars war in The Jackal
and it was fallout of the night Gwen
Stacy died so back in 1971 really one of
the landmark stories in the comic book
industry as a whole was Jerry Conway
killing off Gwen Stacy
never before had something like that
happen it was huge the night when Stacy
died was groundbreaking because it was
unheard of for a superhero not to save
his love interest ever since Superman
swooped down and saved Lois Lane which
he first fell off a building it was a
mainstay that the the superhero the main
guy always saved his love interest she
may have come close to dying he may have
gotten there in
nick of time right before the bullet hit
her but she always lived when stacey
dying changed all that not only that it
also introduced the possibility that
Peter Parker was the reason for why she
died when she was knocked off the top of
the top of the bridge Peter Parker shot
his web sling the yank effect basically
broke her neck or at least some people
say it did but regardless his love
interest died and it set in motion the
idea the comic books could now be darker
that they could be grittier the night
when Stacey died set the set the
groundwork for the Dark Knight Returns
by Frank Miller that's why we got that
story is because we now have the ability
to do darker stories the Fallout
students within the realm of the
spider-man comics was that we were
introduced to a guy by the name of miles
Warren and miles Warren was basically at
least as he was introduced was just a
professor he was just a regular guy now
his backstory wasn't really explained
until the end of the original Clone Saga
all that really happened was that
recently had Gwen Stacy really and it
was kind of crazy because at the time
what this did is it focused on the
nature of Peter Parker and it focused on
the idea that Gwen Stacy may very well
still be alive but of course in his mind
there's no way it could have been true
she had to have been a clone that kind
of a thing now of course this inevitably
led to a conflict between Peter and the
jackal miles Warren and it was kind of a
cool scenario it was kind of a cool
situation in the sense they were just
kind of you know beating each other up
and carrying on and you know the idea of
miles Warren holding this grudge that he
never fully explained it to Peter now at
the conclusion of the original Clone
Saga which took place in the amazing
spider-man 149 really I guess the
conclusion was kind of fleshed out over
the course of 150 and 151 but at the end
of amazing spider-man number 149 what
was revealed to us is that there was a
guy named Anthony serba and this guy was
you know again a scientist or a guy
working alongside miles Warren but it
basically seemed as though Anthony
Surbiton miles Warren were working on
cloning technology Anthony servo was
successful in the idea of cloning a frog
and in turn miles Warren got the idea of
cloning two DNA samples and we didn't
know exactly who they were but of course
we ended up finding out that it belonged
to when Stacy and Peter Parker now of
course with Anthony server basically
realized that it was two humans he was
going to alert the authorities miles one
freaked out tried to stop him and
accidentally killed him in the process
and what this did is it created a
psychotic break in the mind of miles
Warren in the sense that he began to
distance his own actions and creating a
fictional person to have essentially
done it saying well the jackal was the
one who did it not mean you know the
jackal and so on and so forth but by
going through and cloning Peter
worker and when Stacy the first person
to pop up was when herself now of course
when I was basically taken by Miles
Warren and she wasn't documented or at
least had all the memories of her
original self pulled out now that was
the whole basis behind the clones the
clones were created down to a tee so you
know the character that would later
become Ben Riley had all the memories of
Peter Parker this clone of Gwen Stacy
has all the memories of gwen stacy this
was a trend it was basically reworked by
Dan Slott in the clone conspiracy but
the fact remains here that we end up
having miles Warren kind of race off and
that sort of thing but before he does
what he basically says is that all this
is rooted in the fact that Peter Parker
was the one that got Gwen Stacy killed
or at least miles Warren sees it that
way and a Myles mind he as a professor
and it's really kind of weird the way
this is done he as a professor had this
sort of respect for Gwen Stacy's
intelligence the fact that she was so
smart the fact that she listened but it
also bought a line on romance in the
sense that he may have genuinely been in
love with her at least at the time of
this story was kind of ambiguous but
what ended up happening here is that
what Peter Parker tracking Myles warned
down this eventually led to a guy named
Ned Leeds basically being taken prisoner
that kind of a thing sort of used as
bait or used as a hostage and then when
Peter Parker wakes up he comes face to
face with himself now this is a pretty
early indication of Ben Reilly and that
the conflict is pretty fast in the sense
that Peter basically is able to subdue
Ben Riley release I was able to go
toe-to-toe with him while all that while
miles Warren and Gwen stays you're
watching everything unfold now again
they've got like about a minute or two
if we go to this entire fight and for
Peter to win and to free Ned Leeds but
ultimately Gwen Stacy is the one that
turns against the jackal basically gets
them to come back to his normal self the
jackal ends up freeing Ned Leeds but
none of it matters because the bomb goes
off for four squint Stacy and Ned Leeds
and spider-man are able to make their
escape only for the clone to have
basically been killed in the explosion
now that wrapped up things pretty fast
in terms of that original story know
what we're talking about as far as the
whole Neil amazing spider-man scenario
goes what this actually does is it picks
up with a backup feature in spectacular
spider-man 223 and what this did is it
basically focused on the life of Ben
Riley following the events of amazing
spider-man 149 what we had basically
found out was that Peter Parker had
looked around and come to the
realization that if the clone or if the
body of the phone were to be discovered
somebody would unmask it and somebody
would realize that it's Peter Parker
with a very least draw the conclusion
that the you know spider-man is Peter
Parker
because of that the body of the clone
was disposed of only for the body to
have survived and so what this did is it
set in motion two stories the first was
a story called The Lost years which
really isn't relevant I mean it is and
so far as like Ben Riley was alive and
what he was doing but nothing good
happens there I mean it's this short
thing and it's not very interesting at
all but with regards to this story what
this does is it tells us how it was that
Ben Riley got his name and what this
does is it actually picks up within
Riley kind of making his way and just
kind of going through and trying to
figure out what it is that he's going to
do and he's on a bus ultimately the
lessons of stopping you know they kind
of get you know get into a wreck on a
rainy night or some like that and they
end up having to stay in a hotel
but then Riley actually comes upon a guy
by the name of Clifford gross and
Clifford gross was kind of a Skye who's
down on his luck and really has nothing
going on I mean this guy's life sucks
like his wife left him his kids left him
they took all the money I mean the guy's
got nothing on it but it's really kind
of an interesting scenario because this
pits spider-man or Peter Parker as we
would traditionally think of him in
direct juxtaposition with Ben Riley
because Ben Riley's just kind of trying
to navigate his own life while
effectively knowing or believing he's a
clone of Peter Parker and so because of
this this led directly to him just kind
of lashing out yelling at him you know
giving Clifford a hard time and so on
and so forth sort of lashing out in a
bar and that's really about it things
kind of wrap up fast but he ends up
going back to to a room released when a
spider sense goes off he breaks into a
room and finds Clifford's gonna you know
end his life and so of course Ben Riley
basically stops him from doing that but
what this does is it sets Ben Riley's
life in the motion of becoming a good
guy now between this backup feature
going into the official start of the
Clone Saga which was web of Spiderman
number 117 Ben Riley was all kind of
doing his own thing but with regards to
the actual spider-man landscape what we
end up finding out here was that Aunt
May was phased out she'd suffered a
heart attack and she was on the verge of
dying you know and so the idea was that
Marvel wanted to actually kill off her
character now this is again one of the
funny things about the Clone Saga
because this is not an event like it's
not Civil War you know it's not you know
house of them it's not anything along
those lines
this was designed by Marvel to basically
come back and say let's get rid of Peter
Parker because remember this is the
mid-1990s so marvel's whole oh my god
we're on the verge of bankruptcy kind of
thing is really running a lie and it was
one of these moments when Marvel kind of
looked around and said okay maybe the
reason why our sales are struggling
financially is because the fact that
everything is stale so let's get rid of
Peter Parker let's eliminate him let's
bring back then Riley the clone from
the amazing spider-man 149 and let's
have him take the place to Peter Parker
and write Peter Parker out that was
supposed to be a short net really really
quick method of storytelling the problem
was that this story proved to be so
popular that editorial stepped in and
they said just keep it going write
whatever you have to write write as run
a comic about the Sun setting we don't
care what you do but just keep it going
and so what initially started out is
what was likely supposed to be you know
at 10:00 or 11:00 issue story line turn
into 200 plus and by the time it was all
said and done it was so insane that
people were just like this it boggled
them on people didn't know where to
begin because marvel at the time destroy
was written was publishing for different
spider-man stories some of which we're
losing their titles and being changed
over to new title so imagine that you're
reading spider-man and then suddenly
spider-man becomes Peter Parker
spider-man and you're totally lost in
terms of where you're supposed to go
because the numbering remains the same
or something along those lines and it
confused the heck out of people but in
terms of the actual Clone Saga the
officials started this Ben Riley returns
to New York and the reason why is
because of the fact that he learns about
the fact that Aunt May sick and is
almost done with all her living now the
reason why this matters is because of
the fact that going in this road of
redemption for Ben Riley who was
basically catching up and he was trying
to find a way to do the right thing or
trying to be a good guy so he genuinely
cares about the Parker family I mean we
found out you know at the end of a
spectacular spider-man 223 in that back
up feature that when he was asked what
his name was he took the first name of
Uncle Ben and he took the last name of
Aunt May before she was married and just
called himself Ben Riley he genuinely
cares about the Parker family he doesn't
really see himself as Peter Parker but
he still has memories of a life he never
lived he has all the memories of Peter
Parker so he remembers everything he was
taught you know by hope event he
remembers Peter Parker the emotions he
felt the experiences he had what Oakland
died and so what this does is you know
with his arrival
it immediately pits Ben Riley and
spider-man against one another the
reason why that's kind of cool is
because remember Peter Parker as far as
he's aware Ben Riley's dead the Clones
gone he has no reason to believe that
it's still there you know it's
effectively gone forever and so because
of this and the micellar conflict Ben
Riley basically unmasked Peter Parker
and says you know exactly who I am
I'm your clone you know now of course
this brings back all the memories of
Peter Parker has at the original Clone
Saga from amazing spider-man 149 and it
sets in motion the entirety of the Clone
Saga event because Peter Parker believes
he's the genuine one
I'm the real Peter Parker but it creates
a really kind of confusing situation
form because we've been Riley having
returned now the question is is Peter
the clone and has been Wiley the real
one that was the whole basis of the
Clone Saga that was the whole idea was
to basically set things in motion and
kind of caused a little bit of panic
here and there now of course what this
ended up doing is it also introduced a
guy by the name of Judas traveler now
this guy had a couple of appearances
here and there he was one of like the
side plots that went on during the
events of Clone Saga because again
that's one of the reasons why phone saga
was so confusing you had the overarching
Clone Saga event and then you had all
these small events that took place
during a story because again it was
supposed to be a new shift a new status
quo that was supposed to happen so of
course essentially what had happened is
Judas traveler had taken over a
Ravencroft Asylum which is where all the
you know sort of the craziest members
that Spiderman has to face or you know
basically reside at carnage and shriek
and so on and so forth and so it's
basically this scenario kind of this
gauntlet so to speak that if if Peter
Parker loses he'll die if Judas cobbler
loses you know when so on and so forth
but again this was just designed for the
purpose of bringing in the character of
Peter at the same time this was
happening Marvel began to focus more on
the Ben Reilly character and so what Ben
Reilly had basically done is working
alongside Peter Parker at least once
they got there kind of issues resolved
and once they stopped fighting each
other and started teaming up then Reilly
went forward as a new version of
spider-man called Scarlet Spider now the
cool thing about Scarlet Spider is that
he's got his own costume and it is
amazing like Scala spiders costume looks
so cool it's like this 1990s I'm hip you
know kind of thing but the actions of
Ben Reilly running around as Peter
Parker also drew the attention of some
of his own villains most namely venom
now at the same time that this was going
on with regards to venom kind of
tracking down Ben Reilly it also brought
into fray the idea of Marvel expanding
on the symbionts themselves which
introduced a character named scream now
she's not of any real importance here
she was a blip on the radar she showed
up for a little while nobody cared she
went away I just kind of bring that up
to show you guys that there are there
was a huge expansion to the spider-man
landscape under Clone Saga and really
things were just kind of spiraling out
of control that's one of the reasons why
I bring this up but the other half of
this is that the name Scarlet Spider was
not something Ben Reilly organically
called himself right like didn't promise
costume and sake now I'm Scarlet Spider
if he put on his costume and The Daily
Bugle started calling him Scarlet Spider
because only a new is there were
basically two spider-man there was
additional spider-man that we have with
the traditional costume and there was a
new spider-man on the scene and the two
of them were working together now of
course the Daily Bugle being a newspaper
that engages in fear-mongering and so on
and so forth began asking questions like
are they in cahoots with one another do
we have a new criminal in the city of
New York but what this also did is it
began to sort of tease the idea of Kane
now Kane was an interesting character
will get more about him later on I'll
get more into him later on but Kane was
a guy who basically just sort of showed
up and was there for a little bit and
didn't really do a whole lot lingering
in the background and watch things
unfold and that was really about it
that's really all there was to it and so
because that Kane doesn't actually have
any real fleshing out any major role to
play until we end up getting to like the
actual came story itself but getting
back to Ben Riley we're kind of doing
this weird situation this weird hybrid
kind of video where it's like half
telling the story and then like path
explaining things it's kind of a weird
scenario I'm not really used to doing
this so hopefully it works out hopefully
you're picking up what I'm putting down
as we go through this but again which
Scarlet Spider would Ben Riley kind of
acting as spider-man and doing or at
least acting as a version of spider-man
acting a Scarlet Spider this was kind of
a gradual introduction that was the goal
of Marvel was to not just go cold turkey
mama'll couldn't just drop you know
Peter Parker spider-man all of a sudden
I mean they could just have been Riley
show up Ben Riley beats him to death and
then he's like I'm spider-man now that
wouldn't really work people would lose
their mind you had to gradually work
them in and so the best way to do that
was to have then Riley become Scarlet
Spider how Peter Parker remained
spider-man and then have some event take
place where Peter Parker spider-man says
okay now I'm done being spider-man and
Ben Riley takes over the mantle that's
exactly what they do and we'll get to
that you know what cross that bridge
once we get to it but the fact remains
here that again because of the fact that
you know Ben Bailey is scholars fighters
running around being his own hero doing
his own thing eventually venom catches
up to him now the fight between Scarlet
Spider and venom is actually really kind
of cool because in a lot of ways the
Scarlet Spider doesn't really pull any
punches he's you know he's not the same
as Peter Parker he has a lot of the same
believes the same memories so on and so
forth but he's also a little more
ruthless he's also willing to do things
that Peter Parker isn't really willing
to do in this instance he's more
aggressive when he goes against venom
he's more hostile when he goes against
them a couple of his gadgets are a
little bit different and so venom not
quite used to going against this
iteration of spider-man but at the same
time once Venom's basically just kind of
like wrapped up and it just kind of left
by Scarlet Spider ultimately we end up
having Ben
just kind of come to this realization
that after engaging directly with
Scarlet Spider that his his suspicions
are confirmed Scarlet Spider is not the
real Peter Parker and so again this is
kind of a cool scenario because it's one
of these things worse like the plot
thickens kind of the various villains of
Spider Man react to a version of Peter
Parker that's not the real Peter Parker
how do they react to Ben Reilly aka
Scarlet Spider and so again you know
with the two of them kind of facing off
against one another and it's pretty
short-lived it's pretty hard for at the
end of the day
venom is effectively defeated Scotland's
fighters able to bring him down but the
reason why this matters is because of
the fact that this is like the first
major villain of spider-man that scarlet
spiders faced off against and so what
Ben Reilly does in a scenario is he sort
of looks around he looks at the legacy
of Peter Parker all the things that he's
done he's looked around at all the
different villains at each face you know
Kraven the hunter and so on and so forth
and in his mind he's stepping up into
the mantle of spider-man even if he's
not dawn the official spider-man uniform
he's still pretty much acting the exact
same way but the other half of this is
that while all this is going on the
character of Kaine is watching it all
unfold he's watching it all happen again
kind of remaining in the shadows kind of
remaining hidden and that's the way his
character was again you know we'll talk
about him once we get into the Kaine
video but that's the way his character
was he remained hidden almost the entire
time like he was just in the background
you'd see him in a panel over here you
see him in a panel over there you'd see
a panel that would focus on him but he
would never get any explanation on who
he was or what he was about he was just
there this super a magnetic mysterious
guy all that was eventually fleshed out
but it created this question of who is
king what's going on with King who is
this guy what's he about and II see yet
another clone of spider-man but whenever
you said guys hopefully that explains
things and wraps things up pretty well
with the character of Ben Riley again
we're not done with him yet there's
still more to go with the character of
Ben Riley but I feel like that's a
pretty good opening salvo for the whole
Clone Saga to give you guys an idea of
everything that's going on again we
would have done this in our traditional
form but the problem is in order to do
that we'd have to cover all two hundred
some-odd issues of the whole Clone Saga
and it is an absolute mess so we're
really just kind of hitting the
important points and going forward from
there but if you guys are new here to
come this explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the Rob
port you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you guys drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]